Welcome back.
So we're on problem number 9.
In the figure above,
AD is equal to 1.
So AD, this distance right
here, this is equal to 1.
DC is equal to square
root of 3.
So this distance right here
is square root of 3.
What is the value of z?
And they say, no, it is
not drawn to scale.
Clearly.
Because this is longer than
this, but it looks the same.
OK, so they want to know
what the value of z is.
So what can we figure out?
Well, the one thing that pops
out at me is these are both
right triangles.
So this is going to deal
with right triangles.
And the first thing we
see is that these two
angles are the same.
So these two angles
are the same, and
this is a right angle.
We don't even have to know this,
but we immediately know
this is a 45-45-90
triangle, right?
Because the angles have
to add up to 180.
Two of them are the same.
You could say 2x plus
90 is equal to 180,
and solve for it.
But what you also know is that
this is an isosceles triangle,
where two sides are the same.
I don't know if you remember
from geometry class, if you
have a triangle like that, and
this angle is equal to this
angle, then this side is going
to be equal to that side.
I forgot what the property's
called.
I think it's just equal angles,
equal sides, or base
angles-- well, whatever.
Hopefully you remember that
term in geometry.
In this case, these two angles
are the base angles, so if
this is 1, then this
is also 1.
This BD is also going to be 1.
And this is going to be square
root of 2 or something.
So that now, if we look at
this triangle, something
interesting should pop out at
you, if you're familiar with
30-60-90 triangles.
This side is square root
of 3 times this side.
What do we know about
30-60-90 triangles?
And you could even turn back
to page-- if you don't
remember, they give
it to you, right?
They even tell you, right
here, that on a 30-60-90
triangle, on page 423 they draw
it out for you, actually.
If you have a 30-60-90 triangle
like this, and this
side is 30, and this side is x,
then this side is going to
be x times the square
root of 3.
They literally give that to you
on page 423 when they give
you their formulas.
So this side is 1.
This side is 1 times the
square root of 3.
So z must be 30 degrees.
It's a 30-60-90 triangle.
If they asked you why, this
would have been 60 degrees.
And then, if you wanted to know
what this side would have
been, it would have been 2, just
using 30-60-90 triangles.
All right.
Let's move to number 10.
Hopefully that's not
too confusing.
If it is, just review 30-60-90
triangles, and look at that
formula on page 423.
Number 10.
If 30% of 40% of a positive
number is equal to-- so 0.3--
30% of 40%.
So 0.3 times-- but I don't want
to use times, because
they want me to use
x for the number.
So 0.3 times 0.4-- so that's
30% of 40% of a positive
number-- so that's x,
is equal to 20% of
w% of the same number.
So that equals 20% of w%.
So if it's w%, then we could
write that as w/100.
So if w was 50, that'd be
50/100 or 0.5 times x.
Well, we can divide both sides
of this equation by x.
These cancel out.
And then we just literally
solve for w.
And actually, I probably didn't
even have to write it
as a decimal.
30% of 40% of something--
well, we can just
multiply the decimals.
What's 3 times 4?
It's 12.
There's two numbers behind
the decimal.
So this is 12, which
is also 12%.
Is equal to-- and then we
say 0.2 times what w?
What number?
Let's say times w.
Well, I shouldn't write w.
I'm going to write this as y.
And I'll tell you why.
Because this will give
w% as a decimal.
So I'm just saying 0.3
times 0.4 is 0.12.
And that's the same thing
as 0.2 times what?
Well, you divide both sides by
0.2, you get y is equal to
0.12 over 0.2.
And that is equal to 0.6.
And you could review decimals
if that didn't make a lot of
sense to you.
So that equals 0.6.
So y is 0.6, or w% is 0.6.
So the same thing
as 0.6 is 60%.
So the choice is B.
That might seem a little
complicated.
And the tricky part is really
just making sure that you're
not using decimals and then
assuming that's a percent, or
vice versa.
The important thing is
we took 30% and 40%.
When you multiply those two
together, that's the same
thing as 20% times w%.
And I like to put it
all in decimals.
You could have put it all in
fractions as well, actually.
It actually probably would've
been the easiest. You would
have said, 30% is 3/10,
times 4/10 is equal
to 2/10 times w/100.
I took a 0 out.
You could have said 30/100,
40/100, like that.
And then this actually would've
been easy, because
you could have just taken the
100's off of both sides.
You said 30 times 40
is 20 times what?
And then you would have gotten
w is equal to 60.
Actually, that's how I
should have done it.
But anyway, hopefully I didn't
confuse you too much.
Next problem.
Notice I do these things
in real time.
The negative is maybe I don't
give you the most optimal
solution at first, but I think
the positive is that you're
not seeing just a
clean solution.
You're seeing how someone, the
thought process that they go
through when they tackle
these problems.
And I think that that's
actually a super
useful thing to see.
Because when you see these very
polished presentations,
that person did the problem
ahead of time, and so they
just give you the answer.
But they're not showing you kind
of how they stumbled upon
the answer.
So I can only hope that
this is useful.
All right.
Number 11.
This looks exciting.
OK, I'll switch colors.
Let me draw this thing,
and I have the perfect
tool to draw it.
Oh, no, I didn't want
it like that.
So a big rectangle like that.
And they took half
of it like that.
No, no, no.
Edit, undo.
I've got to go half.
My eyes aren't working.
It's roughly half.
And then they take half like
this, and then they
take half like this.
Well, they keep doing it.
Like that.
Then they take a half
like this, then they
take a half like that.
At least drawing this is fun.
OK.
I think this is what they have.
And then they actually
shade in that last one.
So let me shade in
that last one.
I shaded it in in white.
But anyway.
In the figure above, rectangle
ABCD-- that's the whole
thing-- is made up of seven
non-overlapping rectangles.
The two smallest rectangles
have the same area.
So these two have
the same area.
Each of the other rectangles
have twice the area of the
smaller rectangle.
OK, and it looks that way.
The area of the shaded rectangle
is what fraction of
the area of the rectangle
ABCD?
Well, let's just chug
through this.
So let me find a
suitable color.
So this is x.
Oh, I'm still using the
rectangle tool.
If this is x, and this
is going to be
x, this is 2x, right?
If this is 2x, then
this is 4x.
Because they say that
each larger one
is twice the previous.
So this is 4x.
So this is going to be 8x.
Am I doing this right?
8x.
And then this is going
to be 16x.
to be 32x.
The area of the shaded
rectangle.
And then, we could just
sum all of these.
But we also know that
this is half of the
entire rectangle, right?
This rectangle right here.
So the entire thing is 64x.
This times 2.
Because this makes up half
of the entire thing.
So the entire thing is 64x, so
x is going to be 1/64 of the
entire rectangle.
There.
That's it.
All right.
Number 12.
Oh, no, I'm almost
out of time.
So I'll do number 12
in the next video.